time management type stuff that's  another thing eventually that comes with  time what are you serious no so just  yeah keep that in mind and Jack is  probably like no gross with guy at work  I think three day old sandwich on my  desk man like Jax just like I want  roaches guys oh you know like a oh he  slapped me he's a freakin slab me man  yeah I mean like I'm not wrong in this  Derek I am I like Jax like probably  wanted a grocery guy hey there do this  copies of every time you shut your  beautiful mouth  and do you need something Derek hey  Derek could you get these figures over  it's hard for me thanks champ  Derek though the office is sort of  notice you're getting smashed and  watching cartoons at work could you stop  what  Derek you had your presentation ready to  go yet yeah sure  what so yeah those are my favorite days  of the week  like that you like that way huh no no no  wait  well as Todd I find this hostile bond  that way huh